the jurgen experience
if you're a child the things you hear
and see and do are shaping you
right kids come home saying things
they've never even heard before it's
amazing
and as an adult you have to crack into
that neural circuitry and reshape it
but why is that what what is it about
adults because
i have my own theory and this is just a
martial arts based theory
young kids learn so fast they learn so
fast
but i always feel like it's because they
don't have jobs they don't have a family
to take care of they don't have a
girlfriend who's on their back they
don't have
bills and the irs breathing down their
neck they don't have anything
so they can just think about it and
their mind like
if if they have a hard drive right and
they have a one terabyte hard drive they
got like a hundred gigs full
they have all this space you could fill
that space up with technique and
movement and
and it becomes their whole life because
it's thrilling and it's exciting to
learn and their body heals quicker
so they can they can force themselves
into situations with adults it's
extremely difficult to find the
bandwidth
to find the amount of time to really
completely focus on something because
you have so many distractions
does that make sense that oh absolutely
what you just described is
a beautiful description of the top
contour
and below that what's happening is in in
childhood the whole brain is literally
more plastic because there's more space
for the neurons to move around and make
new connections
the whole environment the chemicals that
are swirling around in there
are set for plasticity because we were
basically designed to come into the
world
and be customized to our experience i
mean if the human animal
is exceptionally good at any one thing
it's that so if you're an adult
say if you're a 35 year old man with a
family
or a 35 year old woman with a family and
a job and you want to learn a new skill
what is the best way to force your brain
to accept these new patterns
and learn this quickly by
attacking two separate parts of a
process neuroplasticity is not an event
it's a process and has two parts the
first one is if you want to learn and
change your brain as an adult
there has to be a high level of focus
and engagement
there's absolutely no way around this
because so focus
and intensity and that kind of the
goggins phenotype right i think gog is
now a noun a verb and a
pronoun right it's like it's amazing so
if you're going to goggins this process
we need to do is you need to regardless
of how agitated you feel
you have to lean in and focus extremely
hard
now the reason for that is that there's
a neurochemical norepinephrine
also called adrenaline same thing that's
released in the brain and body
most people back off at that point
because they feel this agitation
but we have to remember that that
neuroadrenaline was designed to get us
into movement that's the purpose of
noradrenaline to take us out of
stillness and into movement
and then the other thing we have to do
is we have to take that elevated level
of alertness
and we have to focus it and there's a
second neuromodulator called
acetylcholine
which is secreted from this little
structure in the base of the forebrain
when we
visually focus on something or in the
case of maybe if you're doing auditory
learning when you
focus with your auditory attention can i
pause you there for a second yeah
so acetylcholine you could take in a
supplement and norepinephrine you can
actually
get from uh float ice tanks
like you can get it from cryo chambers
you can get it from cryotherapy
so using those strategies of taking like
acetylcholine is actually an alpha
brain one of the supplements my company
cells when you
take that along with float tanks and
doing or excuse me cryo chambers and
do some intense exercise or whatever
you're trying to get good at with
intense focus can those things
accelerate that process
almost certainly increases the
plasticity the rate of plasticity
so you would recommend if someone was
trying to get better at something like
a cryo chamber would actually accelerate
the process of learning
yeah so uh yes so so the reason for that
though but you don't necessarily need
a cryo chamber what you need are so we
have these requirements we need urgency
and focus
to trigger plasticity right that's one
part of the process i haven't
mentioned the second part yet
neuroplasticity is triggered when
urgency and focus combine acetylcholine
is released
for the aficionados out there it's
called the nucleus basalis but that
doesn't matter there's a little
compartment of neurons in the base of
your forebrain that doesn't like to
release acetylcholine on a regular basis
it's a it's greedy it's greedy and it
doesn't want to use that with your child
it'll
rain your brain with acetylcholine but
as an adult
30 40 updates why is that because
the you know mother nature designed us
to learn what we need to learn and then
do that
reproduce and die i mean not to be you
know how rude dark about it but
i would say evolution is not about us
it's about the offspring
right 100 you know it's and it's not
even about them it's about their
offspring
exactly never ends we are being
manipulated from the inside yes
i mean that's what it you know kind of
drew me in neurobiology is that all
these complex things you see in the
world
it's all internal so
you know if you get urgency it can come
from
let's use david as a he's a shining
example of this right you can sit there
and just
ramp up your level of urgency through
purely psychological means
you could take an ice bath you could do
high-intensity breathing anything that
brings your level of alertness
up can i ask you this if you were going
to try to improve your ability to get
better at something
when would you use that ice bath or the
cryotherapy would you use it before
would you use it afterwards definitely
before before
before the learn what we're talking
about is a two-part process the first
part is the learning trigger
the learning trigger is gated by two
things adrenaline which is also
norepinephrine same thing and
acetylcholine
and so you need that level of alertness
up and you need acetylcholine
released at the location in the brain
that corresponds to what you're trying
to learn
so things like supplements and certain
nutrition regimens can assist the
process for sure there's no question
about that
things like alpha gpc caffeine will
bring up the adrenaline and kind of
anything to raise that alertness
[Applause]